Justin Liang:
Sympoh's genesis can be traced back to 1998, when four students somehow managed to find
each other, through our mutual interests in breakdancing, martial arts, gymnastics and
Justin Liang:
total disregard for self-preservation. It wasn't long before we decided we were going
to try and pioneer Princeton's first-ever breakdancing crew, because at the time, no
Justin Liang:
such outlet existed.
Mimi Onuoha:
I was surprised that Princeton had a breakdancing crew. When I came here, a lot of the things
that I looked at were mainly the academics and the atmosphere of the campus, so when
Mimi Onuoha:
I came here and I saw all the different performing arts groups, I was actually amazed.
[music]
Brian Calvert:
If you are going to ask me for my... my personal interpretation of what Sympoh is, it's...
it's for me, it's like an avenue of self-expression and self-development and a great stress relief.
[music]
Karin Tsai:
I love being in Sympoh, and especially being a girl in Sympoh. I mean, right now we’ve
almost half of us are girls now. We've formed a sisterhood, and we love our Sympoh brothers, too.
Karin Tsai:
Tonight the girls' piece, I think we all really enjoyed, we all really bonded over that,
and we just really want to represent hip-hop from the feminine point of view.
[music]
Jeremy Blum:
Battling is definitely one of the most intense things in breakdancing and in Sympoh, but
you know it's what drives us to keep on practicing and keep learning new techniques.
Jeremy Blum:
People come up with sets, you know, a general sequence of moves they want to do, but the rest is just free-styling,
just linking moves together and just letting your muscles take control,
Jeremy Blum:
and trying to do something that you know will look cool in the end, or that you hope will look cool in the end.
[music, cheers]
Joseph Choi:
Breakdancing is something that a lot of people never even dream of trying, and I'm glad that
I've found the opportunity here at Princeton to really try something that I find amazing
Joseph Choi:
and a lot of people find amazing as well.
Brian Calvert:
I think when I finally leave the "orange bubble," walk out FitzRandolph Gate and get my degree
and go on to grad school: A, I'm gonna have the connections, the networks, the friends
Brian Calvert:
I've made through Sympoh. B, I'm gonna have the discipline and hard-work ethic that it's
instilled in me, and of course, all the great memories.
[music, cheers]